uh I don't know if you guys are
following what's going on with China
with the development that they have
going on in China with their biggest uh
uh uh Evergreen ever not not even ever
Grand there's a company that's even
bigger than that it's called Country
Garden or something like that if you can
pull up Country Garden some weird name
these guys had a 441 billion won Revenue
last year in 2022 they just missed their
debt payment they literally just you
know how much their debt payment was 20
million won they missed the debt payment
how do you miss the debt this is kind of
like by the way it's a 441 billion yuan
company a year
just missed a 20 million dollar debt
payment that's like you're making just
to kind of put things in context Tom can
you do the math on that it's like you're
doing it yeah if you want to do that
real quick do that if I'm doing 441
billion dollars that's nine zeros right
you miss a 20 million dollar debt
payment am I doing that correctly Adam
so that's like doing what take this take
this take this take this out no that's
like you're making 440 one thousand
dollars a year and you missed a twenty
dollar payment yeah it's nothing that's
what they just missed it's supposed to
be nothing wow they missed it because
they accelerated so you know you know in
China they have a city in China uh uh
the the Paris of China have you followed
the story The Paris of China uh can you
pull this up there's a city in China uh
uh that is
twanburg I think Tia duching this is a
city Tia duching they've built every
single thing the same way it is in Paris
in Tia duching that city right there is
chandelier identical the Eiffel Tower
same size identical can you go pull up
some uh type in Tian du Chang copy paste
that and go to uh go to uh uh Google
type that in the right next to put Paris
by the way just write that shout out to
your French the accents you just
go to images it's called uh you know
having a friend that sat in front of you
that was French for a couple semesters
sounds like a nice person so so look at
that identical same exact thing in China
so what are these guys doing they're
spending so much money do you know how
many vacant homes they have in China
right now do you know how many vacant
homes have in China right now do you
know the number Millions 55 to 90
million estimated vacant homes and their
unemployment right now for ages 15 to 24
years old 15 to 24 years old ages 15 224
it's around 140 million people right
there it's 21 22 right now unemployment
correct they have so much problems going
on in China why because the the knob you
control as a country if you cool and
heat it up and not allow capitalism to
do it you're eventually becoming God
you're acting like God like don't worry
about it we are the gods of economy we
are Jerome Powell we are you know fed we
are the US government we are the
Congress we can do whatever we want to
fix the economy and then all of a sudden
you fabricated so much so much success
that China yet last year lost 10 800
millionaires that left the Exodus of
millionaires in China they're estimated
to lose 13 500 millionaires this year
and guess what last year in 2022 400
people in the world
fell off the billionaire list guess how
many was from China out of the 400 228.
wow let me say this one more time out of
the 400 228 fell off the billionaire
list and they're out of China so bring
this back to U.S I think we need to stay
at a seven point mark for a minute and
Realtors and loan officers I would be
saying this the message he gave which
was important let's go back to where we
were at in the 80s and 90s and this may
be the new Norm this may be the new Norm
and I would talk to my clients and I
would if I'm a loan officer right now
real time I'm going to say this listen
get this thing at seven percent today
here's why say the rates drop to five
and a half percent next year we'll refi
yeah but get it at least at seven
percent to get you because you're going
to get out of good prayer good price
because the problem is what if it stays
at seven percent what if it goes to
eight percent what if it goes to nine
percent lock it in at seven when it goes
lower we will refi that would be the
approach I would be taking because if
America plays with fire on wanting to be
the god of economy all of a sudden we're
going to wake up on there and saying
what the hell are we going to do with
all of this debt that we got going on
anyways so that that's that's the mess
that's going on in America I wanted to
kind of revisit some of the China stuff
because because I think what you're
saying is
uh very important because why is China
important you know one of the biggest
lessons I've learned many of the lessons
I've learned since value table one of
the biggest lessons is the threat of
China you know what's the China by 2030
China by 2025 20 25 20 35 every year
they kind of keep pushing it back a lot
of those predictions were pre-coveted
though but since kovid uh some of the
um information that they've been so uh
secretive about and they've been playing
close to the vest have sort of come to
light why because a lot of people have
been examining China and if you look at
the Wall Street Journal they've actually
done a great job we definitely Advocate
you reading the journal but here's some
of the headlines of the Wall Street
Journal in the last week number one
you talked about
um the unemployment rate of uh China's
youth right 21 so the Wall Street
Journal article says China's young
restless and jobless youth unemployment
doubled since coveted 21 by the way the
government is now telling college
graduates college graduates to settle
for low-paying blue-collar jobs they're
they're quote it's okay to lie flat and
that you should work hard jobs why
because you should learn to eat
bitterness this is some of the
um vernacular that's coming out of China
interesting the second article was has
China is China passed its peak all right
cool good to know uh after everything
that's going on channel that'd be
interesting to do and then you talked
about this uh sort of the billionaires
you said 222 millionaires 28 out of the
400 228 ridiculous number billionaires
we remember in 2020 when Jack ma went
missing and why did why was Jack ma in
the headlines because he's probably the
most famous person of tech billionaire
out of China Alibaba but there's so many
multi-multi-millionaires billionaires
whose names we don't know who who knows
what's happened to these guys we've seen
a tech Crackdown in China but here's the
the third article that I that I read
um Wall Street Journal China will hunt
you down so whether you're Jack ma
whether there's billionaires whether
you're uh the uyghurs that we've learned
about in uh work camps
um or whether you're you know living in
Hong Kong and you're living in fear and
you know what we know about China is
they will suppress any dissenting voice
that dares to question the CCP but
here's what's interesting about China
because for years I've we've talked
about the threat of China you know the
red communism CCP
um what was the the Admiral that we used
to have on
the gentleman who used to have a show
Spalding General Spalding I learned a
lot from him he was great
um here's what we've seen since China
all right the GDP has dropped they're
they're um
foreign investments have dropped
significantly I want to say it's 14
percent since covid uh they call it the
decoupling of China aging population we
can talk about that for a second uh
tourism is as plummeted Who the hell's
going to China these days nobody okay
foreign investments we talked about
evergrant and the other uh real estate
firm what was it called that you just
mentioned uh country uh something so you
know they have a name for these cities
they're called ghost cities yes they've
basically built up these cities with the
expectation that millions and millions
of 60 to 90 million uh residences have
been are vacant right now and nobody's
moving there so these ghost cities are
literally empty talk about listless
vessels nothing going on there but we
all know that in China there's no
freedom of speech there's no internet
there's no social media you can't
question the CCP but let's take a step
back and talk about
um GDP so we all know that um United
States is the number one country in the
world GDP so we're about what 25
trillion dollars I want to say China uh
distance second 18 trillion when it
comes to GDP right there you go so 17 18
trillion there it is and then it's not
even close when you go from three to ten
three to twelve
when you go 25 U.S you go 18 China and
then you have very far down below that
you got Japan Germany India UK and
France all in that three to four
trillion dollar range then you've got
like what I call the twos you got Russia
you got Australia you've got Italy
Canada Brazil Australia they're all
basically below two but here's what's
interesting China you know as as well as
they're doing as from a GDP standpoint
number two in the world there's actually
another term that they call GDP per
capita you're familiar with this it's
like all right not how much not gross
domestic product that the country is
outputting it's how much per person take
a guess where the United States is GDP
per capita don't pull it up Rob versus
China just take a guess
per person per person like rankings in
the world so if we're number one and
China's number two GDP
total GDP where is it per capita take a
guess or you got uh what 23 trillion
divided by 335 million that would be the
US number you really about football held
this math right now and then you would
do 18 trillion in China divided by what
two billion 1.4 billion yeah
so what do you have tell us all right
nobody wants to guess the rankings all
right fine my head hurts all right guys
we want to play this game so number one
in the world is Pat's uh arguably
favorite country uh Monaco if that's
considered a country uh a a region uh
south of France south of Italy uh so
Monaco and Luxembourg number one in
terms of GDP per capita so let's move
that out of the way United States
holding strong at but number seven in
the world that's money in each person's
pocket so China
um not in the top ten not in the top 20
not in the top 50 they are number 64 in
the world meaning meaning there's some
rich ass billionaires yeah and some very
very poor people in real china they've
been obviously over the last three
decades their middle class has been
rising what a point you just made yeah
by the way fantastic point that that you
did the research on that to share with
us I will tell you Rob can you pull up
what I just sent you uh uh okay can you
go to the charts edit the dates go to
the the right above you it says calendar
right next to the plot right there so
you write the click on that and change
the 2022 to 1980. just change that to
1980. okay check this out yeah and then
put the space between it now you kind of
messed it up yeah there you go right
there click on that okay zoom out a
little bit zoom in zoom in a little bit
so we can see it no no no no no Rob
okay go back to the day still okay there
you go so so bring this in so the
audience can see this so this is Japan
and go up there you go perfect so this
is Japan okay the perfect comparison of
China to see what's about to happen to
them is Japan and they look at the
growth Japan had this is their Dow Jones
it goes from 5 000 in 1980 all the way
up to 40 000 in 1990. one of the fastest
growing economies in the world this is
when Toyota was God and their seal was
Jesus okay look what happens to these
guys when they try to fabricate what
fake economy and cheap money
quickly developing everything look how
that thing goes from forty thousand in
1990 it drops all the way down to what
four thousand six thousand and two
thousand okay 2002 and then stays there
at around two what year is that right
there if you look at if there's a take
you there okay it's okay it's a 2002 and
then you go to the next bottom that you
show it's around like 2009 whatever that
bottom is there
and since 1990 till today guess what
it's never gone back to what it was
still haven't recovered yet they're
getting close still haven't recovered in
33 years they haven't recovered what
China is going through right now is
catastrophic is what they're going
through right now they're going to try
to fake it till you make it for as long
as you can but let me tell you something
when you when you fake it till you make
it like imagine when you're hanging out
with a crowd and they're all rich and
you're trying to act like you're rich so
you go to a restaurant hey uh yeah let's
do a bottle of you know whatever just
bring it as good yes
guys hey just bring us all the Torah
From The Underground area of Japan where
only the president eats it yeah bring us
that's like I'm gonna go to the bathroom
real quick yeah and then all of a sudden
the bill comes out guys the bill is
thirty eight thousand dollars a splitted
between four of us look man it's it's 95
how much you guys let's tip this guy
this guy was a good let's tip from 10
grand 50 Grand 12 500 if you want to
give your credit card like oh
what's going on here you know there's
been
China has been living off of fake money
for a long time and their people are
starting to realize and they're slowly
wanting to leave it's kind of like this
you know how you want to leave the party
and nobody knows yeah yeah you're just
going to leave them make sure nobody
sees me here boom I leave that's kind of
what the people in China are trying to
do they're trying to leave China without
the government or the economy knowing to
go to a different place and try to take
their money out quietly but you can't
take your money out quietly it's called
it's called an Irish exit let me say one
more stat and I'm going to hand it over
to my God the biz dog who you know he's
going to give you some good stats the
last thing that I think we should bring
up is everything that you've highlighted
with India this past year India has now
officially surpassed China as the
world's most populated country uh I
think India is at 1.5 billion I want to
say China's at 1.44 in the in that range
whatever the number is depending on how
many people are missing this week
um but interesting enough because of
their aging population due to their a
lot of it the effect of the one child
policy a lot of young
female babies went missing because you
know you wanted that that male son uh
here's China's population in the next
hundred years it's expected to go from
1.4 billion this year to 1 billion by
2080 okay to below a billion 800 Million
by 2100 so in the next hundred years
there you go boom stats right there so
you know what's the one idea I'm always
saying like hey Pat more chicks you know
sounds cast by the way tune in today you
know you're not helping them you got to
make kids so until you have kids when I
want to see I want to see don't make
this personal Junior Adriana Junior
sitting next we're working on that Pat
there might be a couple baby mamas but
let's not deviate but here's the
difference the one child policy has
basically turned China into an all dude
sausage fest party yeah yeah man that's
awesome so United States clubs in
Kentucky I used to go oh no fun by the
way do not try to come in all dudes to a
club in South Beach never gonna happen
so in the United States you have 9 98
males to 100 females so you walk into a
party there's a couple more chicks
you're like all right cool I can get
down like this that's kind of how clubs
operate typically you want more women
than men that's you know supply and
demand it's you know hypergamate its
finest but in China it's 105 men to a
hundred females so you walk into a party
it's like God's sausage fest up in this
piece that's what's going on in China
especially with the Aging population old
men running around the country Tom I
really appreciate your dive into it I
love listening to Stats like that and
one thing I'll add to Adam is remember
one thing about Japan Japan the 90s was
the decade of Crash and then the Otts
the oos was the decade of slow growth
back and they finished 2010 at 10 000
where you saw that there so they sort of
finished where they started in 1980 and
they've kind of grown past that one of
the ways that they've grown in Japan
they have a currency that's tied to
international monetary system the then
is actually actively a part of
international monetary trade currency
trade China has never ever ever pegged
its currency to the international
monetary trade they've never pegged it
they've artificially adjusted the value
inside turning the knob which is the
same problem that Stalin had and if you
want to go back and look at this in
history with his five-year plans that he
started in 1920 Five-Year Plan we didn't
make it well we're gonna make another
Five-Year Plan oh we didn't make that
another Five-Year Plan and the human
toll was terrible so when you sit inside
yourself the way China is now and the
way Stalin did what happens is you don't
get where you're going you're going to
end up somewhere else and that's exactly
what's happened here and at least Japan
learned after 20 years of strife decaded
crash decade of flat they're now coming
back but they're coming back on rational
economic policy and a currency that is
tied to all the rest of the world
currencies where you go up and down
based on the value you create by the way
the the challenge here for these guys
is you know everything is about looking
at other case studies to learn for
yourself if you can't learn from other
people's mistakes
and you repeat it you know that's your
fault it's you didn't you didn't process
what the other person's mistake was
China's not learning from Japan and we
as Americans are not learning from
history we also keep printing more money
hoping to delay the problem to the next
phase and the next phase and the next
phase this whole thing was about we
should stay at around seven percent I
think we should stay at seven percent
Plus for about a decade and see what
happens it'll discipline every by the
way I'm going to lose money if I do that
because value is going to come down but
I think we need to stay at a disciplined
number for a decade let's get stabilized
no more printing of money at the US
government unless if they can lower by
10 if you can lower our national debt by
10 you can come back and ask for more
money to be printed by us if not don't
come back asking for more money let's
just pump the brake you know there's
freezes in different Industries let's
put a freeze in Congress printing more
money for about 10 years let's see what
happens what if publicly we announced
you can no longer print money unless if
a natural disaster happen you can't say
more entitlement more this more that
let's go for 10 years and see what that
looks like but knowing the the the way
our uh government has set up that is
very highly unlikely so if you like this
clip and you want to watch another one
click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
foreign
[Music]